- This a big lie
that you have spoken out
against for a long time,
you should feel very vindicated
over the past few weeks.
- I'm feeling pretty
vindicated lately.
- Because the big lie
we've always heard
is "Oh, these college campuses,
"these are just a
bunch of idiots.
"Just wait until they get
out into the real world."
Well, I'm looking around
the real world now,
and I'm seeing the consequences
of those college campuses
as the buildings are burning
down all around the country.
(rhythmic instrumental music)
- This is the Rubin Report,
and I'm Dave Rubin.
Don't forget to subscribe
to that YouTube channel
we've got over there, and
click the notification bell.
And joining me
today is the host of
"The Michael Knowles
Show," on The Daily Wire,
and a best selling
author, Michael Knowles,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Dave, thank you for having me.
- How have we not
done this before?
Something doesn't
seem right here,
like the universe is sort
of lining up right now,
but how did this not?
- I like that it took a
pandemic for us to really,
and I don't, are we
allowed shake hands?
- Do you wanna shake hands?
- Can we?
- I'm gonna shake your
hand on camera because
you know this, I think,
but the rest of the
world doesn't know this,
on Super Tuesday, which
was, what was that?
February, was that March,
it's like March 2nd?
- It was a while ago.
- That was like right at
the beginning of corona.
Super Tuesday, I'm with
you guys at The Daily Wire,
just as corona's bubbling up,
you are the last
hand that I shook.
As I was walking out of there,
I shake Shapiro's hand,
I shake Klaven's hand,
whoever else in the crew.
And then I walk out and there.
You're the last
one that I shake,
and then we went into
lockdown the next day.
So short of David, I have not
touched another human being.
- I am the last one.
- Yeah.
- And according to the
latest medical science,
if you ever get corona,
it's my fault I think.
- Well the best part
of that is that,
then it turned out that
I guess a few days before
you were at, where were you?
- It was at CPAC.
- You were at CPAC,
and it turned out
somebody at CPAC
shook somebody's hand.
And I'm like, man, I'm
gonna get coronavirus
now because Knowles was at CPAC.
- That's right.
- He shook my hand.
But yet we're both here
and we're both healthy.
- We both survived.
It is so funny because
right after that,
the reason that became
a big story at CPAC
is I was there with Senator Cruz
and we were doing
this live show.
- Yeah.
- We were in the
green room, and there
were a lot of important
people in the administration,
there was like Kellyanne Conway,
Ronna McDaniel, the
head of the GOP,
all these, in this
very small room,
and one guy tested
positive for coronavirus.
So all of a sudden, you
have all these people
locking down quarantining
for weeks and weeks,
and I thought I've just
ruined The Rubin Report
because I'm the last
guy that he touched.
- But not only The Rubin Report,
if this had had the
veracity that they told us
it was going to have,
you would have taken
out The Daily Wire,
out half of Los Angeles,
and yet we're all here.
- Well, because
we found the cure.
You know, we found the
cure to coronavirus,
which it turns out is a
nationwide race riots.
- Racism.
- Yes it's, I thought it
might be hydroxychloroquine,
I thought it could be
they maybe get a vaccine.
Nope, turns out race riots,
that's the cure to the virus.
- Although you're being
slightly sarcastic there,
you know we've had public
officials that have said that.
That is literally said,
if we get the second wave
of corona it will not be
because of the disease itself,
it will be because of racism.
This is what one of
the commissioners of
New York City said.
- Not just one.
There was this
letter that came out,
a couple of weeks ago I think,
it was about 1200, over 1200
public health officials,
who said there are riots,
they didn't say riots,
they said there are
protests going on.
- [Dave] Peaceful.
- Peaceful, very peaceful,
social justice protests
against racism, those
should be encouraged
from a public
health perspective,
but the protests what
went on a few weeks before
against the lockdowns,
those must be discouraged
because they are mostly white,
and frankly I don't even
know if that's true.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And this was the kicker.
They said from our
perspective as scientists,
we know that white supremacy,
which is totally a real thing,
white supremacy is a
public health threat
that exacerbates coronavirus.
This was a shock to me.
We don't know much about the
virus, but we do know that.
- How do you feel being a
pundit in the stupidest time?
(chuckling)
I've been thinking
a lot about this.
- I think this is the
best time to be a pundit,
to be in politics, because we've
been living in this fiction
for actually a
number of years now,
which is that there
is science, right?
And science with a capital
S, trademark over the E,
is, you can't
argue with science,
science tells you what to do.
We bow down, and pay obedience
to the God of science.
And what we're finding out
is a lot of this science
is not so certain.
It's actually a little bit
more political than all that.
I mean obviously in coronavirus
they've basically admitted it.
- Are you telling
me that the WHO,
the World Health Organization,
could potentially, occasionally,
possibly be wrong about things?
- I would never
want to contradict
the Chinese Communist Party.
- We are on YouTube, I don't.
- Yes.
- They'll take us all out.
- Exactly.
- But this is the issue.
- But that sort of
thing, where it's like,
I mean, because we're so
in the same world here,
I mean, that we have
to believe these people
the second they say something,
even though two weeks later
they say the complete reverse
related to masks
or whatever it is,
and then we are doing
this on YouTube,
and I'm sure they're gonna
suppress the views on this,
but the simple truth
is YouTube said
you can't contradict the WHO
which contradicts
itself at the time.
- Right.
- What the hell
are we doing here?
- You see it on the masks,
they say, surgeon general
of the United States
said do not buy masks,
they will harm people
if you buy the masks.
Don't buy masks, then later
you have to buy the masks.
The disease will be
spread on surfaces,
the disease won't be
spread on surfaces.
The disease will be spread
by asymptomatic people,
the disease spread by
asymptomatic people, right?
The list goes on and on,
and actually it gets
to a distinction you
talk about a lot,
the distinction between say
progressives or leftists,
and classical liberals, right?
What the progressive
project has been telling us
for 100 years now is
forget about politics.
Forget about debate and
persuading your fellow citizens
and engaging in questions,
and making ethical choices.
Just pick some
experts in lab coats,
they are going to find
the disputable answer,
they're going to tell you
how to live your lives,
and even if they contradict
themselves the next day,
we just have to
do what they say,
and I think what we're
beginning to learn now is,
no, we actually have a right
to speak about this too,
we're not just going
to blindly follow you.
- What do you think the
psychological underpinning
of that is with progressives?
Because I get it, I've
thought a lot about this,
I wrote about this, like,
what do you think it is
about the progressive
mind, that they pretend
they're anti-authoritarian
all the time,
and yet they love
authoritarian voices actually.
All their policies
are authoritarian.
All the, every time
there's a study
that proves what they want,
then that's the right
study and everybody else
is the racist study,
or something like that.
But do you think that is like
a psychological reason to it?
- I do.
I think it actually, it's,
it's a philosophical and
psychological reason,
and it goes back to Karl Marx,
and it actually goes back
to this idea of science.
So if you go all the way
back to the word science,
science just refers
to knowledge.
It comes from the Latin word
for knowing things, right?
And yet now the one
science has been minimized,
it's been truncated
into this little, tiny
aspect of material inquiry,
and empirical inquiry, right?
So, everything else that we
have to say about knowledge
is kicked out of that.
And what Mark said was he
discovered a science of history.
And this is what
progressives say.
It's right there is
the word progressive,
is we're progressing
towards something,
it's inevitable, Barack
Obama used to always
quote Martin Luther King
Jr. who would always say,
"The arc of the moral
universe is long
"but it bends toward justice."
Basically meaning we're
inevitably hurdling
toward this progressive utopia,
and you can stand in the
away for a little bit,
but you're not
really gonna stop it.
And so--
- And don't forget
history will judge you.
- And history, you'll be
on the wrong side
of history, right?
All of this language
basically turns
politics into a science,
and the reason it does that
is so that you can't
disagree with it.
And that's, you know,
science is always right,
you can never disagree with it.
And what we're learning now is
that was just an excuse,
that was a facade,
to cover up their
political choices.
And so I think the
authoritarian impulse there
comes because they know that
we're going to paradise.
They see the utopia
right ahead of us.
And so if you stand
in the way of utopia,
you can only be
one of two things,
really evil, or
extremely stupid,
and either way, we shouldn't
be listening to you,
and the funny
thing about this is
they think the word utopia
means the best place.
But it doesn't mean that.
The word actually means no
place, it doesn't exist.
And I think a lot of people
are waking up to that.
- Well there's a
semi-autonomous zone in Seattle
I would think is their utopia,
or whatever the hell
is going on there.
How old are you?
- I'm 30.
A lady never tells, but I'm 30.
- Okay, you're a young fella
out there in the
political world,
and I always find it interesting
when I meet younger
conservatives.
So especially now at college,
when I meet younger
conservatives because I think,
although I do think
this is changing now,
for at least a decade,
really more than a decade,
probably a couple decades,
to be a young conservative
was just like,
you're just sort of
this dorky, stuffy,
whatever you're
a nerd, you know,
you care about numbers,
you don't know
anything about culture,
you're not funny, you
don't like comedy,
or any of these things.
Were you always a conservative?
And how do you see that
sort of changing right now,
because I really see it
changing at the moment.
- I see it, I
mean, I think we're
in the midst of it
changing pretty radically.
I basically came out of
the womb smoking cigars
with parted hair, you know,
wearing penny loafers.
- That must have been
a difficult birth.
- It was tough, my
mother is a saint.
There's no question.
1996 I campaigned around
my first grade classroom
for Bob Dole for President.
I was the only person in
America, including Bob Dole.
- Do you have a pen?
- Yeah I did.
I said Bob Dole, no I loved,
I don't know why,
I think I liked him
because he was a war hero,
Clinton was a draft dodger,
but I don't know, I had
this conservative impulse.
I went through a liberal phase.
It was short,
I was like maybe 14,
15 something like that.
- I thought you were gonna
say second and third grade.
Second and third grade, yeah,
and then I totally
I found myself.
- What was that liberal
phase for you, though?
- You know, I
think it came about
because I grew up in
a very liberal place,
I went to a very liberal school,
all my friends were liberals.
It was simply not--
- Where are you from?
- From New York.
From Westchester, New York.
- Oh, right you're
from Westchester.
- That's right.
And it's just not acceptable.
It wasn't even a possibility
to be a conservative.
And so I went along with that,
and then I started slowly
questioning things.
I mean I was an
atheist from 13 to 23,
basically a 10
year period there,
and those religious questions
tie into some political
questions, but I
think over time,
it became clear to me that
there are more possibilities,
and this is something I
actually have a lot of pity
for left wingers who
live in left wing places,
and go to left
wing institutions,
which is they don't know
what they don't know.
See conservatives do know,
we see the other
side of the argument
24/7, you can't help it.
And so, because your ideas
are constantly under attack,
you've got to refine them,
you've got to change them,
maybe you throw some out,
maybe you double down on some,
the left doesn't have
that privilege, you know?
And so I think part of the
reason why they scream,
and they shriek, and they
set up autonomous zones
in Seattle and they,
it's because they
don't really know why they
think what they think.
And, you know, conservatives,
we have the fortune
of being able to
think through that.
- Yeah, I mean I've
talked about that a lot
because it's like
you guys own culture,
and then on top of it you
also created safe spaces,
what did you think
was going to happen
when all the people
over the last, you know,
five years were
yelling at guys like us
for talking about what was
going on on college campuses.
"Oh it's just a bunch of kids."
You know?
And it's like,
actually, you do know
that this is leaking
out into society,
and these people are graduating
and they're starting to
take down institutions,
literally, you have young
editors at publishing houses
that are getting books canceled.
- At The New York Times.
- And the New York Times
has been taken down.
Do you think this thing
is going to destroy
virtually every liberal
institution that we have?
- So this is the big
lie that you have spoken
out against for a long time,
and you should feel
very vindicated over
the past few weeks.
- I'm feeling pretty
vindicated lately.
because the big lie
we've always heard is,
"Oh these college campuses,
"these are just a
bunch of idiots.
"Just wait until they get
out into the real world."
It's like, well, I'm looking
around the real world now,
and I'm seeing the consequences
of those college campuses
as the buildings are burning
down all around the country.
- Yeah.
- The issue of the
institutions you bring up
is an interesting one because
we've been told for
the past few weeks
that all of these protests are
about institutional racism,
right?
But then it occurred to
me, the left controls
every major
institution in America.
- Yeah.
- It controls the media,
it controls higher education
and lower education,
it controls Hollywood,
it controls big tech,
it controls
administrative government,
basically, other
than talk radio,
and some other parts
of the internet,
the left controls
every institution.
So if there's
institutional racism,
who's fault is that?
- Well not only
who's fault is it,
but they are the ones putting
it into the institutions,
they're the ones
making it systemic.
Harvard.
Harvard says we want
less Asian people
because you guys have had it
too good through hard work
and education so we're going
to institute a racist policy.
I don't know if you saw it,
I just tweeted last
night or this morning,
this thing in
Tacoma, Washington,
where there now, it is
going to be in practice
that if you have lost
your job or need housing
because of COVID, they're
only going to help people
who identify as people of color.
- Well that makes it easy.
- I think you might
have something to say.
- I might, you
know, the Sicilians
have a little wiggle room here.
Right, I mean you saw this
with Uber Eats, right?
- Oh love this one.
- They come out, they say,
if you're ordering from
a black owned business,
whatever that is, I don't know,
are you going to
measure the equity here?
A black owned business
there's no delivery fees,
but if it's a white
owned business
there will be delivery fees.
- So they are the ones actually
injecting racism
into the system.
- Of course, but
that's the point.
You know, it occurred
to me, I thought,
a friend came up to
me the other day,
said, "Michael, it's almost
like they want us to be racist,
"the mainstream media, the left,
"they're ginning up
this racial division,
"it's like they want
us to be racist."
And I realize they do.
They actually need you
to be racist because
so much of liberalism
is about overcoming
this oppressive past, right?
So the whole story
of liberlism is--
- It can't end.
- It can't end, you've always
got to be freeing yourself.
But look around, you
remember early on the riot
s the mainstream media tried
to blame white supremacists.
How many Klansmen
are there in America?
Like four left or something?
I didn't see a whole lot
of white hoods out there.
I saw a white hood on
the governor of Virginia,
the democrat Ralph Northam.
I didn't see it in the riots.
So they have to either
create this Boogeyman
or actually try
to create racists,
if only to have a
villain to then overcome.
- Well also, when they're
going through these cities,
destroying everything, we were
talking about West Hollywood
which is literally the
gayest place on earth,
they have rainbow crosswalks,
the entire West Hollywood
right now as we tape this,
is boarded up, I
used to live there,
I went there a couple days ago,
it is boarded up, it looks
like a third world nation,
and on every sign
outside it says BLM.
The implication being
don't destroy our business,
we're for you
Black Lives Matter,
but watch what I can do here,
if that was white supremacists
that were rampaging
through the neighborhood,
wouldn't you be writing like
white power on the sign?
Because then you go, oh
I'm a white supremacist,
you're a white supremacist,
don't bust up my business.
- Of course, and also
it's worth noting,
this is Pride Month, right?
So I thought, like
call me crazy,
I'm not an expert, I
thought this was supposed
to be the month to
celebrate West Hollywood,
and the LGBT
community, but that,
progressivism changes so
fast that now Pride Month
is canceled and now
Pride Month is BLM month,
what's it gonna be next year?
- You remember a couple
years ago at Toronto Pride
when they stopped,
BLM stopped the march
and said you guys
can't March any further
unless you sign our edict
or our, whatever it is,
and basically they did
and they let the march in,
a bunch of us talked about it
and they said oh
here you go again,
here guys go again.
- This issue of the
intersection of politics,
it's an interesting one here
because you're almost
seeing the return
of more of an old
school Marxism.
You know, for the past 10
years you've been hearing
about how the gay community
has something in common
with the trans community,
which is kind of ironic
because there's two communities
sort of contradict one another.
Either there are
individual sexes,
and same sex attraction is
having to do with the two sexes.
Or there's no such
thing as sexes
and so that contradicts
the G in the LGBT, right,
but both have something
to do together.
You can have Gloria
Steinem, radical feminist,
holding hands with Linda
Sarsour, an Islamist,
at The Women's March,
that makes sense.
But now you're
seeing I think begin
to fade away a little bit
into more of an old school
the Black Lives Matter interest
is not the LGBT interest,
and the BLM one is going
to take precedence,
even though all of
it comes down to
a sort of radical
Marxism, and this,
this is the part that I think
some of the squishy
types don't get.
Because say the word
black lives matter,
nobody disagrees with that.
Here's my evidence that
nobody disagrees with that,
everybody posted the black
square on social media.
Everybody, everybody
in government,
in media, in corporate America,
all your friends,
they all did it.
No one disagrees
with that statement.
- Even people that
didn't want to do it,
not because they're
not for black lives,
but because they don't like
being bullied into things,
they did it too.
- They did it too.
But then you look at the
Black Lives Matter website,
the About Us section.
And it's not just about
Black Lives mattering,
at one point it says, "We
exist to destroy the,"
quote, "Western prescribed
nuclear family."
What does that have to
do with police brutality,
or, it's obviously, and you
can see the founders of BLM
come from radical
leftist organizations,
which get their funding from
the Open Societies Foundation,
which is run by George Soros,
that's not a conspiracy
theory with nonprofits--
- Can I say, it's not
antisemitic to say that?
- I don't even, how would it be?
- George Soros
has lived his life
to basically fund every
Jew hating thing there is,
pretty much, right?
- Right.
- He would love to have
Israel wiped off the map.
So the idea that saying
that George Soros
funds these things
is antisemitic is
complete nonsense.
- Right it becomes,
what the left wants to pretend
is that this is a racial
issue primarily, and it's not.
The left he uses race all
the time, but it's not.
You can see when you look at the
About Us section
of the BLM page,
when you look at who's funding.
It's primarily ideological,
and I think there
are some squishy
conservatives and republicans
who want to go along with it
because they were afraid
of being called racist,
even when they're
not about racist.
But that's a very
bad deal to get into
because then you're accepting
radical leftist premises
that are going to undercut
everything you stand for.
- In many ways, though,
do you think the ship
has sailed to the point that
we don't have enough power
to fix this thing?
That you're still
laying out sense,
and thoughtful analysis, and
people are waking up to it,
and I do think a
ton of red people
are being red pilled
right now because,
because just reality is
red pilling them, right?
I've got Hollywood
lefties, friends,
that are calling me and they're
like where do you get a gun?
So it's like, so
something's happening here.
But in many ways do
you think that the
destructive force
of this thing has
so infiltrated everything
that nothing can return?
- You've hit the nail
on the head, which is
we're beginning to see,
more people than
just conservatives or
classical liberals,
just normal people
are seeing, yikes,
something has gone
seriously wrong here,
and yet very little is
being done to stop it.
You see, even a president
of the United States,
more or less all he can
do his tweet about it.
And people are saying,
okay enough tweeting,
you gotta actually do something.
But it gets back to
the institutions issue.
The left controls
the institutions,
which means the left
controls the levers of power.
The only institution that we've
got on the right is talking,
and so we can talk until
they're blue in the face.
We can point out hypocrisy
until we're blue in the face,
and the left says yeah okay
you've pointed out my hypocrisy,
I still have the
levers of power.
I think what is required
now of the right
and of conservatives
is to take back
actual institutions of power,
and perhaps even
more importantly,
to be willing to exercise
that political power
when we have the
ability to do so.
- So what does that mean?
Rubber meets the road.
What are you saying?
Like actually start
separate universities?
I mean there are some
more conservative
leaning universities, and
some of them have thrived
in the midst of all this,
and University of
Chicago, although it's not
conservative per se,
but they have actually
instituted like an actual
defense of free speech,
and probably won't
burn as quickly
as the rest of
these other places,
but what do you
actually mean by that?
Like what what is the
institution building look like?
- So that would be
a wonderful thing,
I mean unfortunately
I could probably count
the conservative
universities on one hand,
and they're really
great universities.
I guess the silver
lining in the storm cloud
of the coronavirus lockdown
and some of the riots,
is that you're seeing a collapse
in many ways of this decrepit
educational infrastructure
that not only does not
give people an education,
and it does not give people
an ability to have a career,
and it does saddled
them with a lot of debt,
all it does is indoctrinate
them in a very modern,
sort of politics, which is not
worth the cost of admission.
So at least you're
seeing that crumble.
But I think there's
a change in mindset
that's got to come
about a little bit.
Conservatives, maybe
in their nature,
are a little bit timid.
And so this is what
you'll hear a lot.
Whenever we're talking about
some kind of political change
we'll say, well,
we conservatives
can't do something about it.
Let's talk about censorship
on social media
is a good example.
We can't do anything to rein
in the big tech companies,
because if if we allow the
government that we control
to rein in the big
tech companies,
then the left, when
they get into power,
they're not going to use
that power to censor us.
I understand that in principle,
but what that really
boils down to is
we can't do anything
to stop the Left's
current censorship of
us because maybe someday
the Left will censor us.
They're already censoring
us, it's already happening.
- So what do you do then?
I mean, you know
I'm big this topic,
and I started a tech company
in the midst of this.
So what is the right answer?
Because I understand
the original premise
you laid out there, and I
understand the counter to that,
because it's
happening right now,
and the simple truth
is right this second,
although maybe it's maybe
it's slightly altered
because of Trump's
executive action,
but they could do
digital assassinations
on all of us today.
Right now they could
shut down Daily Wire,
they could shut me down, they
could shut down everybody,
like could Trump
really fight that,
would he really fight that?
So what is the answer?
So, Trump is at a
slight disadvantage
because the
administrative government,
the bureaucratic
state, the deep state,
whatever you want to call it,
they stay around when the
elected people come and go.
They are there and
the elected people
don't have actually a
ton of power over them,
all the alphabet people, you
know, the different agencies.
One thing he could do
is push an argument
that Senator Cruz has been
pushing for a long time,
which is that Section 230 of
the Communications Decency Act
creates this distinction between
platforms and publishers.
- So this is what he did
though already, right?
Isn't this what the
executive action was?
- Yes, he took an
executive action
through an executive order,
but the executive
order is more or less
just a letter to the
administrative agency
saying please
consider doing this.
That, I hope it works out.
But ultimately, you
know, an executive order
is often only as good as the
paper that it's written on.
You could use the DOJ
to start investigating
maybe anti-monopolistic
courses of action
when it comes to big tech.
- But this must kill you as
a conservative though, right?
I mean.
- Yes and no, yes and no.
It kills a certain kind
of right wing consensus
that developed from the
80s and 90s and 2000s,
which is that all
government action is bad
and you just have to
reduce government action.
But that's not the whole
of of conservative thought.
You know, I mean that
that was a sort of
conservative thought
that certainly you see
in classical liberalism,
but there's more
to conservatism than that.
And I think we want to be able
to use the government
well, for justice.
I mean, it comes
down to a little bit
of a disagreement you see in
the origins of our country,
in the Federalist Papers,
what is the end of government?
Is the end of government merely
to maximize individual liberty?
We all individual liberty.
James Madison says
in the Federalist,
the end of government
is justice.
And so when you've got
these big tech companies,
probably breaking the
law, flagrantly violating,
you know, certainly
some regulations,
controlling the
flow of information
around the internet
in our republic,
that doesn't seem very just.
And so I think it's
perfectly conservative
to use the means at our
disposal to stop that.
- See it's interesting
because I'm with you
on the argument but I don't know
that the machine that
you're describing
that is so broken and
corrupt could do it.
And I think by
empowering it to do it,
you will only make
the problem worse.
- It's possible.
I mean you're running on risk,
and this is I think
why some conservatives
haven't wanted to
actually exercise
the political power
that we the people
give them every so often.
And it's because
conservatives, naturally,
are a little bit risk averse.
And I think there is
a type of conservative
or right winger, who would
rather lose gracefully
then risk being wrong,
and doing something wrong,
and not looking good
in the history books.
I get it, that's a fair fear.
- Is that what you would say
about the Never Trumpers?
Or I'm trying to have more to
say about the Never Trumpers?
- Sure, I mean,
I think there are about two
Never Trumpers left on earth,
you know?
- You got From and Bill Crystal,
like man, you guys
really love each other.
- Yeah, like, to me
it made perfect sense
to be skeptical
of Trump in 2016.
A lot of people thought
the guy who was a democrat,
or he'd a left winger,
so I kind of get that.
Now, I think it's much harder.
He's been in many ways,
the most conservative
president in modern America.
And, but there are still a few
hardcore people who say no,
it's so icky, I don't like
that we have to risk anything
to try to accomplish something.
But that is the
point of politics
and the left is not afraid.
The left is not afraid of
using the political power
that is given to
them by the people.
I mean that's what politics is.
Politics is not abstract.
Politics is not pure philosophy.
It's a messy thing.
There's a line from
Bismarck, he says, you know,
we all like sausage but we don't
want to see how the
sausage gets made.
- Yeah.
- And so I think conservatives
need to be more willing
to take a risk.
To risk how they look
in the history books,
to risk maybe the
government doing something
they don't like in the future,
because you can't win by losing.
You can't win by we're, okay
we're gonna lose this battle,
we're going to lose this issue,
we're gonna lose this election,
but then in some distant future,
when everything is
perfect and pure,
then finally,
we're going to win.
That's not how politics works.
- So I suspect no
your answer to this,
but do you think these things
should be fought
on multiple fronts?
Meaning there can be a
more conservative answer,
there can be a more
libertarian answer
that's more free market,
I mean that's why I started
Locals, it was like,
I've had this disagreement
with Tucker Carlson
on his show where he wants
the government to do it,
and I said, well, I'm gonna
try the free market side.
I don't have a problem
with that argument
because it's like maybe
we all have to hit it
in different ways.
Look the Prager, you
guys, that you work with,
they got into a
lawsuit with YouTube.
Is Dennis's or, I don't
want to speak for Dennis,
but is the Prager U ethos like,
let's use the law to stop
companies from doing something?
Of course not, but we're all,
we're all trying to
navigate very murky waters.
- And isn't that the
freest market of all?
Is to try all of these different
solutions to the problem.
You're not going to
be able to take down
this monstrous left wing edifice
with one little
narrow pure solution.
That one little narrow,
pure solution might help.
But you're going to need a
lot of different strategies,
a lot of different
tactics to undertake.
And so certainly everything
should be on the table.
You don't want to do anything
that is objectively wrong.
I'm not advocating
that in any way.
But, if--
- You mean we shouldn't just
burn down the Google servers,
I think they're
somewhere in Utah,
we shouldn't just go there and--
- Light them on fire.
- Put masks on.
- In the name of social justice.
Yeah, no, we probably
shouldn't do that.
But, but certainly, I mean
what you've done with Locals
is a great example, right?
Certainly we can
innovate, we can create,
try to create our own
institutions, at least,
create the beginnings
of our own institutions,
and enforce the law that
was already on the books.
Those two things are not
contradictory to one another.
And actually, if we
do enforce the law,
if we do have a credible
threat of enforcing law,
threat of a competitor
to one of these organizations,
that is going to
increase the likelihood
of success on all fronts.
You know, when you've got
something like a Google,
and when you add in all
the other tech companies,
they control the
flow of internet.
That is an amount of
power that I don't think
anybody who is, cares
deeply about the country,
or any of the founding fathers,
or any people who
have thought about
how this republic
is supposed to work,
I don't think they
would be comfortable
with that kind of power
being consolidated.
Whether it's a technically
a private company or not.
- Yeah, does some of your belief
that these things
can be stopped,
is there a biblical sort
of bedrock beneath that?
I mean I always say, if
David could beat Goliath
then maybe David
could beat Google.
Like, I really do believe that,
that it is so embedded in us
that the little guy
can beat the big guy,
that that makes me crazy enough
to try to start my
own tech company
in the midst of
all this, you know?
- Yeah that's such a
great point because
I don't know that they can beat.
I don't know that
the destructive left
that has wrecked
our institutions,
and our political traditions,
and our civil society,
I don't know that
they can be beaten,
or beaten in my lifetime.
But I do know I should try.
And I do know I have
no reason not to try.
I mean I guess that would be
maybe the biblical basis of it
is what do I have to lose?
Why would I, what would
I gain by playing along
and saying things that
I don't believe in,
being bullied into posting
whatever I've got to
post on social media
if I lose my integrity,
if I lose my dignity,
if I lose the things
that I care about?
So I have a slightly
more pleasant life,
that's not a
compelling argument.
- Well, I think a lot
of people watching this
would say, well I don't
want to lose my job.
- Yeah, and it's a real fear.
- I mean, I'm sure you get
this question all the time
on college campuses.
Kids will say, "Hey,
I'm a conservative,
"I'm a libertarian, I
believe in certain things,
"but I'm afraid of
saying it in class.
"Should I say it
in class or not?"
I say, well, are willing
to get the bad grade?
What they're asking is,
how do I do what I want to
do without paying a price?
You can't.
You can't, everything
has a cost.
For me, I've spoken out,
I've said what I believe,
it has cost me certain things.
I go to bed at night,
I'm grinning ear to ear,
I sleep like a baby, I
think probably you do too.
- Yeah.
- It's worth it to me, but
there is a cost to that.
- It's interesting cause I get
that question all the time,
or at least when we were
allowed to travel to colleges.
Remember the old days?
And I once heard Ben,
Shapiro obviously,
give an answer on
that which was that
if you're in college that
in your core classes,
so, meaning if you
want to be a doctor,
in your core classes you
probably shouldn't speak up
because you do
need to move ahead,
and you don't want
to be screwed,
but in some of your other
stuff, you know like,
lesbian dance theory,
like there you maybe
could speak up a little bit more
because it probably
won't take you out.
There was some version of that,
I'm not totally sure if
that's what he feels now,
and for like four
or five years ago,
what I would say is, just
suck it up and get the grade
because you want to get out.
But about four years
ago I completely changed
and I started saying
the absolute reverse,
you must speak up.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- If you don't speak up,
if you're in college, the world
will never be easier for you.
You're not going to
get out of college,
you're not gonna
get out of college
and have a car payment,
and a mortgage,
and a wife, and a dog, and
all these responsibilities
plus all the endless
nonsense of the world,
and suddenly be like, you know,
I'm gonna get brave today.
- Time to lose my job.
- Let's roll, yeah.
So you'll never do it.
So that's what I push now,
but it doesn't mean it's easy.
In fact, actually, it
means it's the reverse.
- This is the same
argument as don't worry
about the snowflakes when
they get to the real world.
No, the real world gets
realer and realer and realer.
And I understand
prudence is a virtue,
and politics changes with time.
Politics is about circumstances.
So maybe it made more
sense at one time
to keep a little bit quiet,
and then you can
try to move here,
but in terms of how
I would live my life,
or the advice I would give,
no, I would say, speak up.
Doesn't mean you need
to go wear your MAGA hat
every time or at
the watercooler,
but it does mean if you
were asked a question
about your beliefs, I would
tell people what you think.
I think it's a good
habit to get into.
Let's not forget that
virtues are habits.
And so if you, if you practice
them from a young age,
you're more likely to
be able to practice them
in older age.
- [Dave] Right.
- And if you don't, if you say,
"No when I turned 60,
then I'm going to start
"practicing the virtues."
I don't know if it's gonna work.
- And the scarier
part is that it's,
I think a lot of
young people think
oh it's when I turn 22, right?
Like, 60, we can all
accept that a 60 year old,
most likely, you
know, although maybe
he's going through like
a later midlife crisis,
and then maybe is going
to do something nuts,
but that probably involves
going to Vegas and, you know--
- Yeah, not practicing
the virtues.
- Right, you're not gonna
go with the virtue thing.
You sort of hit on this, but
I'm curious what you think
the sort of future, how wide
a future conservative
tent can be.
Because I'll drop a little
knowledge for you Knowles,
I'm working on my second book,
and that's kind of the direction
I'm going to go with it.
That what I'm really, it
seems to me that the right,
broadly speaking, has
won the big arguments.
They've won the arguments
on individual liberty,
they've won the
arguments on family,
on belief, at least, in terms
of as an organizer of society,
maybe not at a absolute
individual level,
I think we have a little
disagreement on that,
which I'm happy to talk about,
but that basically got
the big stuff right.
- [Michael] Yeah.
And what I think is for someone
that's on the more
liberal side of that,
my job is to kind of
make sure that they
never go off the deep end
too far right, let's say,
and start coming around
to like, you know,
trying to get violence
out of video games again
like the right
used to try to do.
- [Michael] Right.
- But I know that there's
people on the right,
that you know, want
more religious version
of conservatism,
then there's obviously
the libertarians.
What do you, do you think
that thing can hold?
Because I really
believe that the future
of Western politics,
not just in America,
in every Western nation
is a center right future.
I think we're seeing that happen
across the world right now.
- Yes.
- But how wide do you
think that thing can be
to not to become too big?
- I think you don't
need to worry as much
about the breadth as the object,
what you're fighting against.
Because I do think that there
is a lot of space on the right.
But it's not going
to be the same tent
that we saw in the
Cold War, for instance.
So you will never
find a greater admirer
of William F. Buckley Jr.,
and Ronald Reagan, than me.
Okay?
I really admire those guys.
They fought their battles.
They were fighting
the Soviet Union,
and they cobbled
together this coalition
that doesn't make
a lot of sense.
The coalition was the
social conservative
traditionalist religious right,
and they hated of the
atheism of the Soviet Union.
You've got the
libertarians, you know,
practical anarcho capitalists
on one side, right?
They don't really care
about the religious right
argument at all, but they hate
the collectivism of
the Soviet Union.
You've got the
blue dog Democrats,
they don't really care about
either of those two things,
they care about the Imperial
expansion of the Soviet Union.
They come together,
they fight the Cold War.
- Where do you think
Reagan fits in that?
He's more of like a
California conservative
that kind of shifted, right,
in the midst of all that,
right?
- Anybody who tells you they can
analyze Ronald Reagan
is lying to you.
Ronald Reagan is one
of the most enigmatic
figures in American politics.
I mean this is a guy,
he liberalized abortion
laws in California
more than anybody before him,
and yet he becomes
one of the most
pro-life presidents
in American history.
It's very, I mean I
know that Bill Buckley
had a major influence on Ronald
Reagan over to the right.
I mean, I think there
were a lot of people
of his generation who said
they got mugged by reality.
And I think that's how you
go from the New Deal democrat
into a Reaganite conservative.
- I mean it's what's happening
to these people right now.
- Right, it's happening now.
And so I think that made
a lot of sense then.
I don't think that makes
as much sense right now.
A lot of that kind of
conservatism took on a very,
especially in the 80s
and 90s and 2000s,
an economics first
dimension to it.
People just, they said forget
about any cultural issues,
any social issues, we're just
going to talk about tax rates.
Yeah, that's what gets people
riled up in the mornings.
Slightly lowering the
marginal tax rate.
And it's ironic that
conservatism devolved into that
because the great
philosopher of conservatism,
probably the founder
of what you call
modern conservatism
is Edmund Burke,
and in the most
often quoted part
of the most often
quoted book of his,
"Reflections On The
Revolution in France,"
he said, "The age
of chivalry is gone.
"that of sophisters,
economists, and calculators
"has succeeded, and
the glory of Europe
"is extinguished forever."
And what have we do?
We become sophisters,
economists, and calculators.
- [Dave] We double down.
- Yeah, I don't think that
the future of the right
is a bunch of egghead
people on spreadsheets
talking about how to more
efficiently move markets.
- But you think those
people are part of it?
It's just not the heart of
it, something like that?
- Yes, yeah, I mean, I think
they certainly
can be part of it.
- Yeah.
- But I think what we've
got to be motivated by
is the threat, and
the threat right now
is not the Soviet Union.
The threat is the woke
left, the radical left,
that is literally burning
down cities, as we speak.
Now, who opposes the woke left?
The religious right,
Catholic integralist,
you know, as far social
conservative as you can imagine,
and Dave Rubin.
Last time I checked, you're
not a Catholic integralist.
Not yet at least.
And yet, both of those
groups fit perfectly together
in this tent because we
do have a common foe.
The politics of opposition
is often derided,
but the politics of
opposition works pretty well.
It worked well in World War II,
it worked well in the Cold War.
- Do you think there's
any risk of that
in the long term
because then you
sort of get these
competing interests?
I sense this, I sense
this more from the
Catholic side of this.
- [Michael] Right.
That they're gonna
align themselves
with some people that they
really don't want to like
for this sort of short term win,
even if we all agree that yes,
that's the thing we gotta fight,
but that in the long term,
that's not a coalition
that can hold.
- Well in the long term,
we're all dead, I guess,
as a famous economist once said.
I mean.
- Yeah.
- I think this anxiety comes
from some of the
same pathologies
that have afflicted
politics in recent years,
which is that we think
politics is eternal.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And for the left, politics
has become a sort of religion,
politics is not eternal.
Politics is just how
we all get together
in this civil society of ours,
and politics changes a lot.
It's changed a lot in
just the last four years.
So right now we
have this threat,
and we've got this coalition
that's come together.
Good.
Let's do it, man.
I'm not gonna lose
sleep at night
because of some
hypothetical problem.
If in the future, a different
political circumstance arises,
then I suspect,
as always happens,
the political coalitions
are going to shift again.
But let's not lose the fight
that we're in right now
because of the
hypothetical fight
that we're going to
have in the future.
- So what would you say
then to the conservatives
who would say, all right,
we got a guy like Rubin
who were allied with,
and all the mug lefties,
and the, you know, the
old school liberals,
and blah, blah, blah,
but a decent percentage of them,
as you know I describe myself
as begrudgingly pro choice,
this is the big one
for you guys, I get it.
- It's a big one, yeah.
- And by the way, in many ways
I think it's the biggest one.
But all right, it's
up there let's say.
In my book, that's the
argument I make, 12 weeks,
and I don't deny it's a
life, and a whole thing,
but if you wanna live in a
pluralistic society, okay.
I did not get any hate from
anyone on the right, by the way.
- Of course.
- For this.
I got literally hundreds,
if not thousands,
of emails and certainly
thousands of tweets,
basically people just saying,
"Dave, I love the book,
I'm just not with you
"on the abortion one,
but it's all good."
and most of them say
what you kind of said,
which is, you'll get there.
- You'll get there, we'll
get to it, don't worry.
- Something like that, okay.
But putting that aside,
I think there will be
a certain set within that
that'll be like no, no, no,
that's a bridge too far.
And I think what's happening is,
a lot of the
disaffected lefties,
they're going, I can
never call myself
a conservative because
of the abortion one.
That for them is like the
one with that scares them
and keep them in the
closet on the other side.
- Well one of the political
thinkers, Cardinal Manning,
said, that at bottom,
all religious,
or all political conflict,
and all human conflict,
is theological.
It comes down to
religious questions.
And you know, St.
Andrew Breitbart,
the patron of Hollywood
conservatives,
he had a similar saying which is
politics is downstream
of culture, and then
we know that cult and culture
come from the same root word.
What a cultural worships
defines that culture.
And so at the bottom you have
these religious questions.
And some people write
off religious questions,
and they say well
I prefer science.
Well in the way that
these modern liberals
are using the word
science, it's a synonym.
They're using it in the same way
to talk about eternal questions.
And the question is,
what as a human being,
what is a human being for,
and what does a just politics
do to innocent human beings?
So, I would imagine
that years ago,
you would have called
yourself more pro-choice
than you do now.
- Oh yeah.
- Certainly.
- Yeah.
- You've come over and,
how could I be upset that
you've come closer to my opinion
on the question of abortion?
Why would I be angry about that?
That you, in my view,
have become more correct
on that question.
- Well, I always tell Ben when
I've debated this with him.
I'm always like, listen,
you're making good arguments,
but it's the bananas lefties
that are pushing me out.
- [Michael] Right.
- When they say you can't be,
you can't be pro-life
and be a Democrat,
or when they say you can have
an abortion at eight months.
It's like, I've got
nothing to negotiate
with you guys over there.
At least with you,
I mean Glenn Beck,
who, of courses, is pro life,
I've discussed this
many times with a him,
and even though we've come
to different conclusions,
I find our logic
action is the same
to get there, in many
ways, you know what I mean?
It's like my birth
trying to keep the state
out of people's
lives, and then we can
talk about life and all that.
But that, so I think I
get your conclusion there.
Because it's like, all right,
we can at least
do something here.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- But if you're gonna tell me
that an eight month abortion,
just because someone
feels like it, is okay.
- It's crazy.
- What can I do, what can I do?
- And talk about using
every tool available to us,
you know, we were talking
about that with big tech,
well you can apply
it the same way here.
I think the
philosophical arguments
for abortion are
extraordinarily weak.
I don't think there are
much of an argument at all.
I think all the arguments
against abortion
are very strong,
philosophically.
Theologically, it's
not even close.
It's not even a question.
And then there are
scientific arguments,
and it's hard to make
scientific arguments
because what are going to say,
okay when the when the
baby has its right arm,
then deserves not to be killed?
But before it has its right arm
then it deserves to be killed.
I don't, that's not
very compelling.
- By the way, I don't
know if you read my book,
but I do make that concession.
I do make that concession.
- Right of course, and
so when you see it,
I think, to me, this
is even more important,
maybe, than the arguments.
And this is where science
plays a role in it.
Because of the advance of
science, of medical technology,
you can see the
baby, you can see,
and this is why I
think you would say,
you see the baby at eight weeks.
You say, I can't kill that.
I can look at that and see
that that's a human being.
Maybe you can see
that seven months,
maybe say at six months,
maybe, all the way back,
to me that's very persuasive.
Because don't forget
we're not just brains
floating in the air, right?
Politics is not just pure
philosophy floating in the air.
We're human beings,
we're flesh and blood,
we're moved by images,
and those images
I think are very helpful,
and if some of those
images move you
all the way back to 12 weeks,
to me that's something
that's worth celebrating.
And maybe now then we can
go a little bit further too.
- So with that very pleasant
way you describe that,
with a smile on your face,
I want to talk about
civility a little bit
because somebody
actually, not realizing
that I was having you
on the show today.
- [Michael] Yeah.
Somebody in the Rubin
Report community
put up a post about of civility,
and they said, "Dave
you, and Michael Knowles
"are two of the best at it."
- Oh, it's very nice.
- So there you go.
So somebody likes you, Knowles,
can you believe it?
Pretty great.
But basically what they're
saying in terms of debates,
because you have
a zillion videos
of you debating
leftists and all things,
and you don't put
them down, you know,
you occasionally do some
jokes and that kind of stuff,
but you do engage in ideas,
I've never seen you,
unless there's something
I haven't seen, I've never seen
you try to destroy somebody
or any of the rest
of that stuff.
Where do you think civility
from you comes from?
Because, do you think it's
just sort of temperament
coupled with knowing what
you're talking about?
Or do you think it's
one or the other more,
or something else?
- I think politics
is much more pleasant
if you begin from a
place of humility.
Now, our politics starts
from a place of pride.
Right?
I'm, I've got to get
my way about everything
and if you don't give
me everything I want,
even a little bit, I'm
going to burn your city
to the ground, that's
what we've been seeing.
- Or at least start my
own city within your city.
- Or at least start my own city.
- At the very least.
- And build a lot of walls,
and start a police force.
- We love walls,
these guys love walls.
- They do, only some.
So I think it's good
to begin with humility.
Because especially, you would
be a great example of this,
you've changed your
mind on a lot of issues.
I've changed my mind
on a lot of issues.
So when I'm debating
some left winger,
whether it's a 22
year old college kid,
or whether it's a
52 year old democrat
who goes on cable news,
I can look at that person
and say, "There but for
the grace of God go I."
Maybe I would have
thought that thing
if I hadn't had
this conversation
10 years ago with this person.
I was in favor of abortion
until I had lunch
with a bioethicists,
and she convinced me my
arguments were wrong,
and then I changed my mind.
So I think, well, maybe I
could have that influence
down the line on somebody else.
I don't get angry, really,
in politics you know.
There's an expression,
don't get mad, get even.
And if I can, I'll get even.
- Yeah, you are Italian.
- I am Italian, you know,
and these are important
rules they teach us
when we're two years old.
To me, that's much
more productive.
It's just not my style,
really to, you know,
smack somebody, or ruin them,
or get really
personally, I just don't,
I don't care that much.
I want them to come around
to the right point of view,
I want to have a good politics,
but I don't have
to pull my hair out
and ruin my life for that.
I mean don't forget,
this is still our life,
you know, and if you're
going to spend it
being miserable and
angry all the time,
you're probably doing it wrong.
- Is that the most
dangerous thing in a way?
That these people, these lefties
who now become religious
in their anti-religion,
they've become religious,
in their anti-racism
they've become racist.
But that their whole
view is politics.
- [Micheal] It is.
- Like what do you guys
have besides politics?
I would, you know, I try not
to tweet on the weekends,
during corona it has
not been going well.
- No.
- Because now we don't know
when weekends are, right?
What is the weekend?
But, like escaping, I do my
August off the grid thing.
Like getting out of the day
to day minutia I view as,
it's like more, I can't
imagine how important
it is right now, you know?
People get angry
when they don't know
what they're talking about.
People who know what
they're talking about
tend not to get angry
because very often,
they know what
you're about to say.
They kind of know
the counter arguments
and they can refute
the counter arguments.
So they've just done it before,
they seen where this is going.
The people burning down cities,
the people screaming at you
on Twitter, or wherever,
they don't know what
they're talking about.
Just from a practical level,
when you get angry, you
don't think as clearly.
And I know, there have been
a few times I've done it,
where, I like to think I
can count them on one hand,
where I've sent an angry tweet.
I said I wasn't gonna
tweet on the weekend
and I got, something
got me really angry,
and I tweeted.
- You bastard.
- Those are the only
tweets I regret.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Those are the only
tweets that I've sent
that I think I don't actually
stand by that, I don't really.
It's just from a long
of scale of your life,
it's not gonna be good
if you live your life
angry all the time,
but even just from
a tactical position in politics,
if that's the way you're
conducting politics,
you're gonna make more mistakes.
So, since we've talked a
lot about the conservatives,
and we've talked about
just sort of like,
the general lefty
lunacy that's going on,
let's just do a little bit
on like the political side
what's happening
with the Democrats.
Well, first off, do you think
Biden's gonna be the nominee,
just simple yes or no?
- I watched him yesterday
wearing, he was wearing a mask,
this was a while ago,
he was wearing a mask
dangling from his ear,
it wasn't on his face,
it didn't go to the other ear,
it was just dangling down.
That's not going to
protect him from the virus.
So just from a practical
medical perspective,
I think he's got to figure
out how to do the mask
otherwise he's not
going to do it.
He doesn't seem like he's
in it for the long run.
However you, without getting
conspiratorial about anything,
there's a master plan to kick
him out of the convention,
who are they're gonna
replace him with?
I mean he ran against, what
was it 25 or 27 other people,
and he beat them all.
I get that he's a
horrific candidate,
but I don't really see
anyone replacing him.
What do you think?
- Well, I mean I've been
saying for months now
I think that the
plan sort of was
we just get through the
election to get him there,
and then he's not in charge.
I mean, this guy, he obvious,
I mean this other thing
where they just simply,
the mainstream media,
simply refuses to talk
about his cognitive decline.
- Yeah.
- It's like, that is
a type of fake news.
We all see something and you
guys won't let us see it.
So that's one thing, so I think,
I don't know you bring
in Elizabeth Warren,
well now I know he'll obviously
bring in a black woman.
- Yeah.
- So it's like all right,
do you bring in Condi Rice?
Condi Rice I think it's
actually way better.
- Yeah.
- Not Condi Rice,
sorry not Condi Rice.
- You just did a racism.
You did a, racism, here we go.
(laughing)
- No, who the hell
am I talking about.
- And Dave got
canceled on my episode.
Just my luck.
- Who am I talking about?
Susan Rice.
- Susan Rice.
- I'm talking about Susan
Rice, not Condi Rice.
- I was gonna say Condi Rice,
that'd be pretty good.
Maybe I could wake up with that.
- No, I could vote
for Condi Rice.
- Yeah, Susan Rice is
making a play for it,
she's writing New
York Times op eds,
sort of she's.
- Whew.
It's a good thing I
cleaned that up, that is.
- Which, you know, Susan Rice
could be a real candidate.
- You know, Rubin thinks
they're all the same,
that's what they're gonna say,
but this was more
of a Rice issue.
That was a Rice issue,
you know what I mean?
That wasn't a.
- It wasn't a race issue,
it was a Rice issue.
Right, that's true.
Whew, that was close.
- We don't edit for content
around here by the way.
- That could be a
more serious choice
because the other
options for women,
they said Amy Klobuchar,
Amy Klobuchar has some baggage
when it comes to
criminal justice.
Kamala Harris has
the same thing.
Stacey Abrams is a
punchline, she is not,
she was best known for
losing an election.
Before that, she was
a Georgia State Rep.
Come on, give me a break.
So, you know, Susan Rice
would be a real choice.
The other problem Biden has is,
often you want to
balance a ticket,
so you got the
conservative Reagan,
and you've got the
more establishment,
more liberal George Bush.
Because we see the cognitive
decline of Joe Biden,
I don't think that's gonna work.
It's not gonna make
Biden voters feel better
if there's some radical
leftist on the ticket.
You've got to have a candidate
who's just kind of a younger,
perhaps blacker,
perhaps more feminine,
perhaps whatever
version of Joe Biden,
a more establishment candidate,
and someone like Rice
would fit that bill.
- Right, the only
problem with that though
is that then the base of
these radical lunatics
will gladly destroy
the entire party.
Which I thought was
gonna happen either way.
You know what I mean?
Like you can pick mini
Biden to stave it off,
but that only
delays it slightly.
Or you pick one of the
crazies and congratulations
now you've burned
the whole thing down.
So either way, it's just a
movement of destruction I think.
- It is.
- Like it's inevitable
and basically
I just think the
Democratic Party is over,
like the socialists have
taken over in effect.
- You know, but the
thing you gotta remember
about the Democratic Party is
it's endured for a long time.
You know, they say
they're the longest living
extent political
party in the world.
And part of the
reason they're good
is cause they don't have
a ton of principles.
You know this is why
they were able to last.
Bill Clinton, a man who
believes in nothing.
Right?
He runs as a left winger.
- I know he like cigars.
(chuckling)
Come on, you're a cigar guy.
- I am not that kind
of cigar guy, okay?
I'm not that kind.
So he runs as a
liberal, you know,
left winger in the early 90s,
then by the end of the 90s,
he says, "The era of
big government is over."
Why?
Because he lost the
midterm election
and Newt Gingrich
took over the House.
He has no principles, he'll go
whichever way the wind blows.
Joe Biden is in many ways
this kind of a candidate.
Joe Biden had an actually
pretty good crime bill
in the 1990s, which would
probably the most popular
thing he could run on right now,
and yet he's running
away from it,
and Trump is
hammering him for it.
That shows you how crazy
our politics has gotten.
- Yeah, well he's running away
from all his old positions,
he's running away from
his own abortion positions
that were more
moderate, you know?
And also, correct
me if I'm wrong,
but he was vice president,
am I right on that?
- No, and he was in the
Senate for like 50 years.
No, you know what it is?
This time, now.
Now he can affect change.
Have you seen that
meme where it's like,
Biden's been in for 40 years,
Schumer has been
in for 40 years,
Pelosi's been in
since the 1600s.
Like, it's like,
oh, you guys are all
gonna suddenly do all the,
I'm gonna say shit,
I'm gonna say shit.
- You said it.
- I've been trying
not to say it,
because I think that
usually gets us demonetized,
just a simple, a simple
curse word like shit.
- They'll just look for an
excuse to demonetize you.
- Oh, well I already got
you on, I'm done anyway.
But like, the people
that fall for it,
like what is that?
People that fall for it
every single freaking time?
- So this is what shows you
what Trump is up against,
because Trump is
a weird candidate.
Right?
Trump is in no way part of
a Republican establishment.
I don't think the guy was a
Republican for much of his life,
and he comes in and he
has shaken things up
in a way that other Republicans
were not able to do.
Tn the way he speaks, in the
way he looks at immigration,
in the way he looks at trade,
in the way he looks at other
matters of foreign policy,
all sorts of things.
What you get reminded of,
when you see a Pelosi,
or a Clinton, or a
Biden, or a Schumer,
that is the establishment.
The liberals, the progressives,
they are the establishment,
and they're pretending to
be the subversive culture.
But actually they
control everything,
and the establishment knows
how to protect itself.
Okay?
And the minute that you
have someone, like a Trump
who comes in, and says I want
to change this a little bit,
you have the full weight
of the bureaucracy,
of the Democratic establishment,
of the Republican establishment,
which is just plays the foil
to the Democratic establishment,
they lose with grace,
that sort of thing.
They turn all of their
guns on that guy.
It's the most
radical, ironically,
it's the most radical
moment of politics
that I think any of us
have seen in our lifetime.
- So I'm with you on that, even
for my differences on Trump,
like I do believe that
is the allure of Trump,
and that is in a nutshell.
I'm curious because you've
become friendly with Ted Cruz,
and you guys do a podcast.
Trump is pretty relentless
on him in the campaign,
and yet he's become one of
Trumps biggest allies now.
In many ways, I
always, when I see,
well Cruz has also become
a great Twitter person.
He gets it, he gets
memes, he's funny,
he gets Star Wars references,
like he finally gets it now,
and I actually regret
being so anti Cruz,
because I there was
just something about him
that I didn't like,
it was just too stodgy
for me or something.
- But since you've
listened to the podcast,
you know he's a great guy.
- He is a good guy.
He's funny.
I think he's the
constitutional conservative
in the way that I can get
on board, all that stuff.
- Yeah.
- Have you guys talked
about how he's been able
to put some of the
that stuff aside,
like the personal attacks
that Trump did on him,
and the rest of it, like?
- Well, you know, we
started the podcast,
The Verdict podcast
during impeachment.
So this is the hottest moment
of the Trump presidency.
I mean this is where
everyone is attacking him.
You even had a
couple of Republicans
trying to turn on
him, and gain support,
to throw him out of office too.
And here you have Senator Cruz,
a former opponent
of President Trump.
Now, you know, good stalwart
conservative in the Senate,
defending him.
And really what Cruz is doing
is defending the Constitution.
I mean, you had some liberals,
people like Alan Dershowitz,
who came out and said I am
defending the constitution here.
It is not constitutional
for you to try
to throw this guy out of office.
And I think that's
something I really admire
about Senator Cruz is look,
political campaigns get hot,
people say a lot
of terrible things.
And if you want to
accomplish something,
you can't take that
stuff personally,
you can't hold personal
grudges like that.
And so I've really
admired the way that,
you have, there's
a tough campaign,
you put it behind you, and
you try to get the work done,
because one thing I've noticed
having spent a little
bit of time in Washington
doing this show, and for
other for other projects is
a lot of people who
go to Washington
don't care about
accomplishing anything.
They don't, they want
to be a congressman,
they want to be a senator.
They don't want to do
anything that that involves.
And when you do things,
and I've heard this,
I heard this from the
president's chief of staff,
just a week ago on
The Verdict Show,
when you do things,
you don't get invited
to cocktail parties.
When you do things, people
are very mean to you,
and they ostracize you
and they you kick you out.
But what's the point?
Why else go?
It's not that glamorous a life.
And so, you know, I think Cruz
could not have acted better,
you know, since since 2016.
And I'm glad at least there's
one or two conservatives
in the Senate because a lot
of people go wishy washy.
- Yeah, all right, I got
one more for you, Knowles,
which I think will tie is
up in a nice little bow.
Let's see if we can do it.
- [Michael] All right.
- As somebody that now is
in this world of punditry,
like, we are so
in the center of the center
of everything right now,
the things that we talk about,
the things that we've
been talking about,
we've started to
build relationships
with some of these people.
Like you are now
friends with Ted Cruz.
Like, how much of all this
seems completely surreal to you?
Because I do wake up
sometimes and I'm like,
I can't believe from
somewhere any of us started,
from when I started doing
a little YouTube thing,
or even before that I had a
podcast like 10 years ago,
when I didn't even know
how to download podcasts,
I kid you not, I didn't even
know what a podcast was,
but now we're like
right in the center
of this very strange thing
that everyone is talking about.
I'm just curious sort of
how that fills your life.
- That's personally
very exciting,
but this has been surreal
for me for a few years.
It's been surreal for me
since I told this joke.
I did this joke, I
guess it was now,
it was only about
three years ago,
it was a blank book,
basically just--
- It is literally.
- [Michael] Completely.
- For the people watching
it is a blank book.
"Reasons To Vote For Democrats."
Incredible, by the
way, some of the blurbs
that you got on here.
Dennis Prager read this twice.
- That's impressive.
- He is seriously busy.
- "Insightful, yet remarkably
easy reading," Guy Benson.
Just wonderful.
- Well, thank you, but,
I published this blank
book, I self published,
I did it just as a joke to
irritate my democrat friends,
and then the thing jumps
and becomes the number one
bestseller in the world
for like a week and a half
or something like that.
And so I think I'm the
only guy in the history
of politics to get a show for
not writing a book, right?
So that, and I thought that was
actually a great way
for that to happen,
because we were talking
about religion earlier,
it's a great example
of unearned grace,
you like literally
don't do anything,
and then a lot of
great stuff for it.
So, yes, personally,
it's very exciting.
But I think politically,
publicly, it's
very exciting too,
because the reason
the book took off,
is because of this
weird political moment
that we're in, right?
A lot of reason
the book took off
is because all the
people who bought it
left these really long,
deep reviews of it,
comparing it to Flobert
and all of these kind of
really funny things, right?
The humor really came
from the audience.
Same thing with Trump, right?
I think we just love
that we've cracked
this stale, dead, political
establishment consensus.
There's something new happening
even if we don't always like it,
it's a little scary,
it's a little weird,
but we like that it's happening.
You know if what we're doing
couldn't have
happened 20 years ago.
It would not be possible.
We're living in
a world now where
a corrupt mainstream media
that has lied through
its teeth, and then it's
a lied through its teeth
about lying through
its teeth for decades,
is a punchline.
People don't watch it.
The only people who watch CNN
on walking through airports.
We're living in a world
in which that kind of
silly political talk that
you saw from candidates
this time around
like Pete Buttigieg,
or you hear it from some of the
older establishment
politicians, it's like,
well, you know, "I
believe in this not that,
"I believe in this, not that."
And you read it, and
you listen to it,
and you say, well, what
does that really mean,
because I know he
can't mean this,
I know he has to
write, that's gone.
And now living in the
blunt, direct world
of the way that Trump talks,
the way that with
other people talk.
That to me is what's
so much more exciting.
We've got this
realignment where now,
instead of having to go
through the gatekeeper
of the anchor on ABC News,
who's talking to the
establishment guy, no.
Some guy with a
podcast can go talk
to some of the most
powerful people on earth,
and you can get a message
out that is very different
from that which
has been approved
by the liberal establishment.
To me, as exciting
as it is personally,
to me politically, that's
so much more exciting fact.
- Knowles, that
was a nice ending,
but there is one other
thing I have to do.
- Lay it on me.
- Because as you were the last
person whose hand I shook,
that then, you know,
I never got corona,
now we've done this,
and either way we could be
passing it to one another.
- That's true.
- So I just want
it to be on camera.
- Here it is.
- That, and I think that's
a felony in California,
what we just did.
- Oh no, Garcetti's outside
waiting for us with the cars,
don't worry about that.
It's been a pleasure
chatting with you..
- As always.
- It's @MichaelJKnowles
on Twitter.
- Yes.
- Am I right?
- [Michael] That's right.
- Right out of the brain.
No notes here, no nothing.
All right that's it.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.